[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في حصاد الليله معكم ليلى الشيخ
لي في الوقت الذي احدثكم فيه تقع احداث
وتتفاعل البدايه من القدس تحديدا المسجد
الاقصى وصحاله من الترقب تحسبا لاقتحام
جنود الاحتلال الاسرائيلي المسجد قبل
الاحتفال بعيد الفصح اليهودي
والى طهران حيث وصل وفد تقني سعودي لتقييم
وضع مقر البعثات الدبلوماسيه تمهيدا لفتح
السفاره السعوديه في طهران والقنصليه في
مشهد
والى واشنطن ايضا مباشره حيث اعلنت وزاره
الدفاع الامريكيه ارسال غواصه تعمل
بالطاقه النوويه مزوده بصواريخ موجهه الى
منطقه الشرق الاوسط
وفي مواضيع الحصاد هذه الليله
وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي يامر بمواصله
اغلاق الضفه الغربيه امام عابر قطاع غزه
والغاء التسهيلات المقرره في شهر رمضان
استدعائه اربع سرايا احتياط لحرس الحدود
الاسرائيلي اعتبارا من الاحد
ومخاوف من اقتحام الاحتلال المسجد الاقصى
تمهيدا لدخول المستوطنين صباح الاحد
تحقيقه امريكيه في تسريب وثائق عسكريه
السريه تتضمن لمحه جزئيه عن الحرب في
اوكرانيا تعود لنحو شهر مضى واسرارا خاصه
بالامن القومي الامريكي تتعلق بالشرق
الاوسط والصين
الوصفين قولهم انه من المرجح ان يكون
للتسريب تاثير على الامن القومي للولايات
المتحده عالميا
[موسيقى]
تسير غواصه نوويه امريكيه مزوده بصواريخ
موجهه للشرق الاوسط واشنطن تقول ان الخطوه
تهدف للمساعده في نشر الامن والاستقرار
البحري الاقليمي مسؤولون امريكيون يكشفون
عن معلومات بتخطيط ايران لتنفيذ هجمات في
المنطقه
بعد اجتماع تايواني امريكي الصين تجري
مناورات عسكريه تشمل تدريبا على تطويق
تايوان بمشاركه مدمرات وزوارق سريعه قاذفه
للصواريخ ومقاتلات وطائرات تمويل واجهزه
تشويش بيجين تعتبر المناورات تحذيرا جديا
مما اسمته تواطؤا يتعلق بتايوان تقول ان
المناورات تهدد الاستقرار والامن في منطقه
اسيا والمحيط الهادي
وفي لقائنا اليومي قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه ناقشنا مسارات تعامل الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي مع المشهد في المسجد الاقصى مع
الاعلان عن فرض اجراءات مشدده في محيط
المسجد والبلده القديمه والشوارع المؤديه
الى باب الاسباط ووادي حلوه وباب المغاربه
اعتبارا من صباح غدا الاحد
باستطلاع ارائكم بشان هذا الموضوع كنا
طرحنا عليكم السؤال التالي ما هي توقعاتكم
لتعامل الاحتلال الاسرائيلي مع المصلين
والمعتكفين في المسجد الاقصى الاجابات
جاءت على النحو التالي
[موسيقى]
توقعوا اقتحامات من جيش الاحتلال
والمستوطنين بينما قال قرابه
23% ان الامور تتجه نحو الهدوء في المسجد
وباحثه هذا سؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصاتنا
الرقميه يمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر مسح
رمز الكيو ار الذي يظهر الان على الشاشه
ولقائنا يتجدد على المنصات الرقميه يوميا
نتطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجده
ومتفاعله عربيا ودوليا
كما تتابعون في الحصاد ايضا
في احدث حلقات ماساه طالبين اللجوء مصرع
اربعه وفقدان ثلاثه وعشرين في حادثه غرق
قبله سواحل تونس
قال الجيش الاسرائيلي انه رصد اطلاق ثلاثه
صواريخ من الجانب السوري
لخط وقف اطلاق النار تجاه جنوب الجولان
ونقلت هيئه البث الاسرائيلي ان صواريخ
اطلقت من سوريا باتجاه الجولان احدها سقط
في منطقه مفتوحه فيما نقل مراسل القناه
الرابعه عشر الاسرائيليه ان ثلاثه صواريخ
اطلقت من سوريا سقط احدها في الاردن
والثاني في سوريا والثالث في
متسار في الجولان وقالت المصادر
الاسرائيليه ان السلطات تجري تحقيقا
لمعرفه ما اذا كانت تنظيم يتبع ايران وراء
هذا ام ان فصيلا فلسطينيا هو من اطلقت الك
الصواريخ
واشارت المصادر الى ان ردا اسرائيليا
متوقعا في وقت لاحق هذه الليله ويذكر ان
الجيش الاسرائيلي كان كثف اعتداءاته على
سوريا منذ مطلع الشهر الحالي
ومعنا الان من رام الله مدير مكتب الجزيره
وليد العمري وليد ضعنا في سوره اخر
التفاصيل بشان هذا الموضوع
المعلومات بهذا الخصوص ان الصافات الانذار
كانت قد دوت في مستوطنته ميتسار وهي اكثر
المستوطنه تقع في جنوبي الجولان السوري
المحتل وقريبه من منطقه خط وقف اطلاق
النار وايضا قريبه الى حد ما من الحدود مع
الاردن التي تقع في جنوبها الجيش
الاسرائيلي قال انه رصد عمليه اطلاق
لثلاثه قذائف صاروخيه من داخل الجانب
السوري لخط وقف اطلاق النار ان احدها قد
سقط في منطقه مفتوحه بجانب هذه المستوطنه
بينما الاخران لم يتحدث عنهما لكن
المعلومات تقول ان احدهما سقط في الجانب
السوري والاخر ربما على الحدود مع الاردن
الجيش الاسرائيلي ووفق مصادره فانه يقوم
الان في محاوله للتحقق ما اذا هذه
الصواريخ من يقف وراء اطلاقها هي مجموعه
مواليه لايران ام انه تنظيم الفلسطيني
موجود في تلك المنطقه وفي الوقت ذاته
اشارت الى ان اسرائيل سترد في وقت لاحق من
هذه الليله على عمليه الاطلاق هذه يشار في
هذا السياق الى ان اسرائيل اصلا ومنذ عام
2015 وقد كثفت ذلك منذ عام 2018 تقوم
بسلسله من الاعتداءات المتتاليه في العمق
السوري يستهدف مواقع في منطقه دمشق وداخل
دمشق ومطارها وكذلك حلب وحمص وحماه وغيرها
واللاذقيه بالاضافه الى ذلك لكن اللافت
انه منذ بدايه هذا الشهر كان قد كثفت من
هجماتها وعلى مدار اربعه ليالي متتاليه
كانت تقصف اهدافا في العمق السوري الان
بعد هذا التطور الحاصل والى حد ما هو غير
مسبوق بهذا الشكل ان تطلق الصواريخ من
الجانب السوري على منطقه الجولان المحتل
الخاضع للسيطره الاسرائيليه يعتبر الاس
ذلك بانه عمل او تطور غايه في الخطوره لان
من شانه ان يظهر وكانه فتحت جبهه جديده
بالاضافه للجبهات التي نشطت خلال الايام
الماضيه بين اسرائيل والمناطق المحيطه بها
سواء كان ذلك في غزه او لبنان او الضفه
الغربيه بما فيها القدس الان هناك جنوب
الجولان السوري المحتل لكن المتوقع هو ان
تقوم
الطائرات الاسرائيليه بقصف في العمق
السوري كما كانت تفعل في كل مره شكرا
جزيلا لك من رام الله مدير مكتب الجزيره
وليد العمري
كانت هيئه البث الاسرائيليه ان وزير
الدفاع يؤف جالنت وجه بتمديد اغلاق
المعابر مع الضفه الغربيه وقطاع غزه بسبب
التصعيد الامني في حين ذكرت صحيفه يدعوت
احرنوت ان وزير الدفاع وجه كذلك بتعزيز
الشرطه بقوات من الجيش بسبب التوترات
الامنيه وذلك لتعزيز الامن والاستقرار
مضيفه ان الشرطه ستمنع اليهود من الدخول
الى الحرم القدسي في المسجد الاقصى خلال
العشر الاواخر من شهر رمضان
حديث سبقته قرارات بتعزيز قوه الاحتلال
الاجراءاتها الامنيه وذلك بعد يوم من
اصدار رئاسه الوزراء الاسرائيليه تعليمات
بتعبئه كل وحدات الاحتياط في قوات حرس
الحدود ودعمها بقوات اضافيه لمواجهه ما
وصفته بموجه الارهاب المتصاعده وقال
متحدثا باسم الجيش الاسرائيليين رئيس
الاركان
اجرى تقييما للوضع الامني بعد الهجوم
المسلح الذي وقع في مستوطنه الحمراء بغور
الاردن امس واسفر عن مقتل مستوطنتين
واصابه الثالثه باصابات خطيره وانه وجه
بتعزيز الجهود الدفاعيه في الضفه الغربيه
وكان مستوطنون
هاجموا مساء اليوم مواطنين فلسطينيين قرب
المدخل الشمالي لمدينه البيره في الضفه
الغربيه وافاد شهد عيان ان مجموعات من
المستوطنين المتطرفين تجمهروا بالعشرات في
الشارع الالتفافي الرئيسي قرب حاجزه
مستوطنه بيت ايلا العسكري وذلك بعد خروجهم
مما يعرف بالسبت المقدس وقاموا برشق
الحجاره على مركبات المواطنين والمنازل
القريبه من الحاجز العسكري ما ادى الى
تحطيم زجاجي بعض المركبات
معنا الان من ام الفحم داخل الخط الاخضر
الدكتور مهند مصطفى مدير مركز مدى الكرمل
للدراسات والخبير في الشان الاسرائيلي
اهلا وسهلا بك دكتور اذا هذه الموجه من
العنف والعنف المضاد
ما تاثيرها اولا على الحكومه حكومه
الائتلاف على نتنياهو نفسه
يعني لها تاثير كبير جدا اولا هذه الحكومه
تفقد من مكانتها ليس فقط في المجتمع
الاسرائيلي ولكن ايضا بالاساس وهذا الاهم
في صفوف اليمين وقواعد اليمين هذه الحكومه
جاءت بعنوان انها سوف تعيد الامن الشخصي
والامن الجماعي
للمجتمع الاسرائيلي على ضوء العمليات
المسلحه والتصاعد العمليات المسلحه
الفلسطينيه في ظل الحكومه السابقه وجاء
وجاءت مركبات الحكومه مثل مركبات اليمين
المتطاويه فقلت نحن نستطيع ان نوقف هذا
العنف ولكنها تفشل مره والمره هنالك في
افاق متواصل لهذه الحكومه في تحقيق الامن
وايضا هناك في تصاعد في العمليات المسلحه
الفلسطينيه وهذا ينعكس على مكان تتنياهو
وعلى الحكومه في داخلها هنالك في تناقضات
في الحكومه هناك في نقاش والصراع في داخل
حكومه حول السياسات التي يجب اتخاذها
اتجاه الفلسطينيين وهنالك قيود اقليميه
وقيود دوليه تمن من اتخاذ ذلك هذا سيؤدي
الى اضعاف الحكومه امام المجتمع
الاسرائيلي امام قواعد اليمين وايضا سيؤدي
الى تازم داخلي كبير في داخل الحكومه بين
مركبات الحكومه المختلفه الحكومه
الاسرائيليه الان في مازق كبير جدا جدا هي
عمليه لم تحقق اي هدف من اهدافها فيما
يتعلق بالامن الشخصي والامن الجماعي سواء
على المستوى الداخلي وسواء في العلاقه مع
الفلسطينيين ولذلك سيكون لهذه الموجه من
التوتر والتصاعد والامني تداعيات كبيره
جدا على هذا الحكومه وعلى التماسكها
الداخلي كما تصف انت الوضع كانها اسد جريح
الان فما الذي نتوقعه من هذا الاسد الجريح
ان يزيد من التصعيد والى متى وما الذي
يمكن ان يحدث خلال الايام القادمه خصوصا
في المسجد الاقصى والذي يبدو وكانه يحدد
ما سيحصل لاحقا
نعم اولا في الاسبوع القادم سوف نشهد
مزيدا من التوتر في القدس في المسجد
الاقصى هنالك في اعياد يهوديه وهنالك نيه
عند اليهود المستوطنين بالصعود وانتهاك
المسجد الاقصى
حكمت نتنياهو الان تتخذ الخطوه المتوقعه
وهي مزيد من القوه هنالك في تجنيد
للاحتياط هنالك في محاوله لنشر قوات
احتياط من حرس الحدود في داخل الضفه
الغربيه وفي داخل مدن الاسرائيليه من اجل
اعطاء الشعور بالامن للاسرائيليين وسيكون
هناك مزيدا من استعمال قوه اسرائيل في
تعاملها مع هذه الازمات الامنيه عددها
تتخذ مزيد من الاجراءات العنيفه ومزيد من
القوه ومزيد من التواجد العسكري هي لا
تنظر الى موضوع الفلسطيني الا من الزاويه
الامنيه ليس لها اي تصور واي افق سياسي
لحل هذه الازمه وحل هذه القضيه وحل هذا
الصراع كل تعاملها مع الموضوع وتعامل
بمزيد من القوه الان سوف نشهد في الاسبوع
القادم مزيد من التصعيد ان هنالك في اعياد
يهوديه هنالك في يعني توجهات وفي خطط
لانتهاك ساحات المجد الاقصى وطبعا الحكومه
الان في مازق من جهه هي تريد ان تحافظ على
الهدوء تريد ان تفي بوعودها بناء قادره
على تحقيق الامن ومن جهه ثانيه هنالك في
مطالب لجمهور اليمين المتطرف من قواعد
اليمين التي تريد من الحكومه ان تسمح اكثر
واكثر بانتهاك المسجد الاقصى وتسمح اكثر
بالبناء الاستيطاني في الضفه الغربيه وهذا
بدوره سوف يزيد من التوتر الامن اشكرك
دكتور مهند مصطفى مدير مركز مدى الكرمل
للدراسات والخبير في شان الاسرائيلي كنت
معنا من ام الفحم
اثر تسريب وثائق عسكريه سريه امريكيه
يعتقد ان جهات قريبه من روسيا تقف وراءها
مخاوف بشان الخطط العسكريه في اوكرانيا
خصوصا الهجوم المضاد المتوقع هذا الربيع
وتحذر مصادر رسميه امريكيه من ان بعض
الوثائق المشهوره مزوره بهدف تحقيق
الدعايه الروسيه
منذ اندلاع حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا ساد
الاعتقاد ان هناك تفوقا استخباراتيا
امريكيا ساعد كثيرا الجيش الاوكراني الان
يعلنوا البونتاجون انه يحقق في تسريب
وثائق السريه تتعلق بالاعداد لهجوم
اوكرانيا المضاد المتوقع هذا الربيع
الوثائق نشرت في منصات التواصل الاجتماعي
ومنها تويتر وكذا انستغرام الذي يستخدمه
نصف مليار شخص ويكتسب شعبيه كبيره بروسيا
وسائل الاعلام الروسيه نشرت الوثائق على
نطاق واسع فيما يشبه الاحتفاء بنصر
استخباراتي لا يمكن الاعلان عنه رسميا
تقدم هذه الوثائق معلومات حساسه عن الجدول
الزمني لتسليم الاسلحه الغربيه لاوكرانيا
وقائمه بوحدات الجيش الاوكراني ومعداته
وتدريباته رغم انها لا تشير الى تاريخ بدء
هجوم الربيع او مكانه الوثائق بها معلومات
في غايه الاهميه عن 12 لواء في الجيش
الاوكراني يج تسعه منها في الولايات
المتحده ودول اخرى في النيتو ويتوقع ان
تكون سته منها جاهزه في نهايه مارس ويقدر
الخبراء عدد العسكريين في كل لواء بما بين
اربعه الاف وخمسه الاف تشير الوثائق الى
ان الالويه تسعه ستحتاج 250 دبابه وثلاثه
وخمسين الي عسكريه اخرى كما تقدم معلومه
مهمه اخرى عن سرعه استجابه القوات
الاوكرانيه للتعامل مع قذائف هاي مارس وهي
معلومه لم يقدمها من قبل لكن مصادر رسميه
امريكيه حذرت من ان بعض الوثائق المنشوره
مزوره بهدف تحقيق الدعايه الروسيه ومنها
وثيقه تقلل عدد ضحايا روسيا وتضخم عدد
ضحايا اوكرانيا في الحرب ورغم ان بعض
الوثائق مزوره فان البانتاكون يعترف بان
اخرى سليمه وتتضمن معلومات في غايه
الاهميه وقد توقع خبراء لصحيفه ان تستفيد
روسيا من هذه الوثائق المسربه وان كان من
الصعب تح ديد مدى هذه الاستفاده كما
يتوقعون ان تؤثر على تبادل المعلومات بين
الولايات المتحده واوكرانيا التي ترددت
السابق في مد واشنطن في معلومات ميدانيه
خوفا من هذا النوع من التسريبات
[موسيقى]
اعلنت البحريه الامريكيه انها ارسلت الى
الشرق الاوسط الغواصه
us فلوريدا والتي تعمل بالطاقه النوويه
والمزوده بصواريخ موجهه دعما للاسطول
الخامس الامريكي الذي يتخذ من البحرين مقر
له ونقلت صحيفه الوصف عن مسؤولين امريكيين
ان الاداره الامريكيه تلقت معلومات تفيد
بان ايران تخطط لتنفيذ هجمات في المنطقه
قريبا وقالت الصحيفه ان ارسال الولايات
المتحده للغواصه uss فلوريدا الى الشرق
الاوسط بمثابه استعراض للقوه
رساله لمن يهمه الامر فماذا وراء الامر من
تهديدات حركت
نحو الشرق الاوسط
الغواصه الامريكيه التي دخلت المنطقه منذ
يوم الخميس تعمل بالطاقه النوويه وهي
مزوده بصواريخ استراتيجيه موجهه انها وفقا
للبحريه الامريكيه قادره على حمل ما يصل
الى 154 صاروخ كروز من طراز توماهوك وهذا
طراز من الصواريخ يصل مداه 2500 كيلومتر
ويمكنه التحليق على ارتفاع منخفض نسبيا عن
الارض
المهمه الرسميه للغواصه كما تحددها واشنطن
هي دعم الامن البحري والاستقرار في
المنطقه
وعمليا ستدعم الاسطول الخامس الامريكي
الذي يتخذ من البحرين مقرا له وتغطي
عملياته الخليج العربيه وخليج عمان والبحر
الاحمر واجزاء من المحيط الهندي
لا يكشف البانتاغول في الغالب عن مواقع
غواصاته في المياه الدوليه
خطوته النادره تتزامن مع تحركات عسكريه
اخرى في المنطقه محمله بالرسائل ذاتها فقد
ابقى الامريكيون على حاملات الطائرات جورج
اتش دبليو بوش والقطع المرافقه لها في
مياه المتوسط حيث الاسطول السادس الامريكي
وجاء ذلك كله بعد ايام من ارسال سرب من
طائرات اي عشره المقاتله لتعزيز القدرات
الامريكيه في المنطقه
يقرا متابعون في تلك الحشود جميعها تصميما
امريكيا على تنفيذ وعيد وزير الدفاع نويد
استون بان اي هجوم على جنود الامريكيين لا
يمر دون عقاب هي اشاره لا شك الى سلسله
الهجمات الاخيره على قوات بلاده في سوريا
وما تبعها من رد امريكي
لكن الاستراتيجيه كما يبدو استبدلت القصف
بالحشد العسكري والتلويح باستعمال القوات
عند الضروره في تحسب لهجمات مستقبليه
محتمله
تنقل صحيفه جورنال عن مسؤولين امريكيين ان
ارسال الغواصه ياتي اثره تلقي معلومات
استخباريه تفيد بان ايران تهدف لتنفيذ
هجمات بالمنطقه قريبا
وتضع الصحيفه ارسال الغواصه الى الشرق
الاوسط في سياق تحرك الاوسع يقوم به
البنتاجون لتعزيز القوات الامريكيه في
المنطقه وذلك لردع القوات المدعومه من
ايران عن تنفيذ المزيد من الهجمات على
الولايات المتحده وحلفائها بحسب ما جاء في
ولف جورنال ثمه ما يضيف الى ذلك مخاوف
امريكيه على سلامه الملاحه التجاريه في
مياه الخليج وان كانت الدواعي فان واشنطن
طورت هنا بحسب خبراء عسكريين مفهوم ردع
جديدا يقوم على الانتشار الضخم والسريع
ويشمل ارسال قوات استراتيجيه الى المنطقه
خلال ساعات كل ذلك الحشد العسكري المتزامن
جعل القوه الناريه الامريكيه عاليه في
المنطقه ومن اتجاهات عده
ومن الكويت معنا الان الدكتور عبد الله
الشاذي استاذ العلوم السياسيه في جامعه
الكويت وايضا من واشنطن معنا الدكتور خليل
العناني استاذ العلوم السياسيه والعلاقات
الدوليه دكتور عبد الله دكتور خليل اهلا
بكم في الحصاد ابدا معك دكتور خليل اذا
رساله بلا شك ترسلها واشنطن ولكن نريد ان
نفهم فحوى الرساله ولمن توجه تحديدا برايك
مساء الخير لحضرتك والدكتور عبد الله لكل
المشاهدين انا اعتقد انه اولا لابد ان
نشيرا هذه ليستمر التي يتم فيها ارسال
غواصه نوويه حدث الامر اكثر من مره قبل
ذلك اخر مره كان في اكتوبر الماضي عندما
تم ارسال ايضا غواصه النوويه يو اس
اسرع حمل صواريخ باليستيه على الاقل 20
صاروخ وبالتالي الامر قد يكون يبدو وكانه
اجراء روتين لكن بشكل عام نحن وضع الان
مختلف نوعا ما وهناك رسائل كثيره جدا
الرساله الاولى هي بالطبع الى ايران خاصه
في ظل ما حدث قبل اسبوعين من هجوم على
قواعد عسكريه امريكيه في سوريا خاصه في
دير الزور والحسكه واصابت على الاقل جندي
امريكي وبعض وقتل الجندي وبعض اصابات اخرى
رساله قويه جدا من امريكا لايران من نحن
موجودون ولدينا ايضا القدره على الوصول
اليكم في اي وقت وبالتالي هناك حاجه
لاختلف الاعتبار الامر الثاني متعلق في
رايي الشخصي برساله مهمه جدا للصين خاصه
هناك حضور صيني فيما يتعلق البعد
الدبلوماسي والسياسي والاستراتيجي هناك
قويه للصين بانه القوه الرئيسيه في
المنطقه التي تحمل المنطقه العربيه هي
امريكا وبالتالي هناك مجال للدخول في
منافسه في هذا الاطار الرساله الثالثه في
رايي الشخصي ايضا للسعوديه السعوديه
السعوديه تحاول الان ان تقوم باعاده تواضع
في المنطقه من خلال اللعب على التناقضات
بين الصين وبين امريكا وبالتالي تحاول
امريكا
للسعوديه بانه نحن والقوه الرئيسيه التي
قد تحمي المنطقه العربيه خاصه العربي
الامر الرابع متعلق قد يكون في رايي
الشخصي بما اشيع مؤخرا في قيام روسيا ببدء
نشر اسلحه نواه تكتيكيه في بيلاروسيا قد
يكون الامر متعلق بالصراع مع روسيا
احتمالات يكون هناك نوع من المواجهه فيما
يتعلق الاطار وبالتالي وجود غواصه ثانويه
في الخليج العربي وفي منطقه الشرق الاوسط
بشكل عام تعطي انطباع بان هناك وجود
امريكي فيما يتعلق باستخدام النووي بشكل
او باخر كثيره جدا في هذه المساله يجب ان
ننتظر حتى نرى في مرحله المقبله على الاقل
الدكتور عبد الله فيما يتعلق بالرساله
الموجهه لايران
اذا اذا افترضنا ان هذه الغواصه
حسب ما قاله مسؤولون امريكيون وسرابات
الصحيفه ان السبب هو ان هناك معلومات تفيد
باقدام
ايران على عمل يهدد المنطقه الان بعد
المصالحه السعوديه الايرانيه ما الذي يمكن
فعلا ان يهدد المنطقه في هذا الوقت ويثير
المخاوف في الخليج
هذا سؤال مهم جدا يعني الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه واضحه ان في تراجع لاهميه منطقه
الخليج والشرق الاوسط مقابل
الاولويه لروسيا في اوكرانيا والصين طبعا
بالدرجه الاولى ولكن مثل ما ذكر صديقنا
الدكتور خليل عناني من واشنطن ان هناك عده
رسائل يعني هذا طبعا هذه لن ترضع ايران
ايران الان يعني هناك بشكل واضح تهدد
اللعب بشكل واضح الطرف الذي يعزز عدم
الاستقرار هي اسرائيل في هذه المرحله
ايران يعني تتعامل مع المتغيرات بشكل بشكل
فيه نوع من الواقعيه الرساله الاولى هي ان
امريكا متراجعه تريد ان تطمن الحلفاء بان
هي موجوده ارسلت هذه الغواصه التي هي
نوويه وتحمل قدرات مدمره هائله
لتعزيز النظره الامريكي يعني انا منذ
سنوات اكرر بان ولا تنسحب من المنطقه وما
تفعله امريكا الان بارسال هذه الغواصه هو
تاكيد اننا لن ننسحب من المنطقه بل نعززها
هذه الغواصه ستكون ضمن منطقه المسرح
عمليات
المسؤوله عن العمليات العسكريه في البحر
الاحمر وفي خليج عدن وفي بحر العرب وفي
باب المندب وفي مضيق هرمز وفي الخليج
العربي ولهذا السبب في اطمئنه للحلفاء وهي
رساله ايضا لدول مجلس التعاون الخليجي
انكم لا تعاونوا كثيرا على اي قوه خارج
امريكا لاروسيا ولا الصين عندهم القدرات
العسكريه والقتاليه والوجود العسكري
الموجود من الكويت الى مسقط وفي العراق
وفي سوريا
والرساله الثالثه هي ايضا الى يعني
الحلفاء بان نريد ان نطمنكم والى اسرائيل
بالدرجه الاولى والى ايران انها يعني ان
تكفي يد حلفائها او ميليشياتها او من
يتعاونون معها في سوريا والعراق باننا
هناك في قوه في الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه وهي جزء من ما تسميه امريكا
الديتيرنس سياسه الرد التي يمكنها ان اذا
اذا اضطرت امريكا ان تصعد هذا الموقف وان
تطمئن الى حد ما اننا قوه موجوده ولا يمكن
لاحد ان ينافس الوجود العسكري الامريكي
واننا لن ننسحب من هذه المنطقه برقم
تراجعها وتراجع الاعتماد على النفط
الخليجي بالدرجه الاولى وماذا عن
استراتيجيه او سياسه
التي بدات في عهد اوباما او تحول نحو
الشرق والتي ربما جعلت كثير في المنطقه
يشعرون بان هناك شيء من التراجع هل على
الارض في الواقع لم يتغير شيء والدليل
الان ارسال هذه الغواصه ما الذي تريد
واشنطن فعليا ان تقوله بهذا الخصوص دكتور
خليل
الامريكيه يضع الصين باعتبارها وهذا الامر
جاء مكتوبا في وسط الامن القومي في اكتوبر
الماضي تتحدث عن الصين باعتبارات تحديا
استراتيجيا خطيرا يجب ان يتم التعاطي معه
بشكل جيد منذ هذه اللحظه وراينا هناك وجود
في الصين في المنطقه العربيه سبقت من
ناحيه الاقتصاديه كما هو الشائع وهو كما
هو معروف كنقدر وجود سياسي ودبلوماسي
وراينا دور مهم جدا للصين في الالعاب
العلاقات بين السعوديه وبين طهران هناك
حاله تخوف وهناك حاله تحسس في امريكا من
هذه المساله بانه عندما يتم اعطاء مساحه
للصينه ده يعني ان هذا خصم نفوز امريكا
وبالتالي انا اعتقد انه هناك حاله قلق
امريكا واضحه جدا قد يبدو هناك نعمل
التخبط مع هذه المساله بمعنى اخر هل يتم
اعاده التمور الاستراتيجي فيما يؤدي الى
يعني وجود نوع من
التواجد الصيني ام يؤدي الامر الى ايضا
تخفيف وجود امريكي من اجل التوجه باتجاه
دعم اوكرانيا في الحرب على روسيا وهناك
حاله انا رايي الشخص حاله اعاده مراجعه
العربيه سوف يتعلق بوجود عسكري نشط وقوي
قد يمثل امتداد لنفوز المنطقه عقود طويله
حتى هذه اللحظه دكتور عبد الله توافق على
ان وجود فعلا تخبط بعض الشيء في الجانب
الامريكي القلق الذي تحدث عنه الدكتور
خليل للتو برايك هو مبرر في هذه المرحله
هل البيجين فعلا سجلت نقاط على حساب
واشنطن في المنطقه
طبعا سجلت نقاط يعني حتى في تقارير صحيح
في تخبط ما في استراتيجيه واضحه لامريكا
يعني قبل اسبوعين اعلنت عن سحب مقاتلات
متطوره اف 16 من المنطقه واستبدلتها بفندر
بلطيا طائرات قديمه خمسين سنه حاصده
الدبابات ماذا ستفعل يعني هذه تستخدم في
المعارك في الحرب العسكريه
ولم ترضع احد يعني فيه تخبط لا يوجد في
استراتيجيه واضحه في اتفاق امريكي انسحاب
مرتبك وفوضوي من افغانستان
عدم اعطاء دول الخليج اي نوع من الطمنه
بالنسبه الى يعني اذا حدث التطورات هل
امريكا ستكون موجوده لما قصفت ايران منشات
او خريص في السعوديه ب 2019 ترامب اللي
كان هو الذي ينظر اليه بانه هو الحليف
الرئيسي في المنطقه لدول الخليج والسعوديه
قال هذا
يونايتد سبيس مو مشكلتنا هذه هذه منذ ذلك
الوقت صار في انفتاح اكثر على ايران صار
في تقارب اكثر مع ايران وصلنا الى الان في
وقت سعودي يعيد فتح السفاره والقنصليه
العامه اليوم في
طهران وفي مشهد ودخلت على الخط
تقرير تقرير اليوم في الامس في وسائل
الاعلام الامريكيه ان ويليام بيرنز
يعني مدير الاستخبارات المركزيه يقول
بالتقارب السعودي الايراني والسعودي
السوري ويعني يبدو بان هناك لا يوجد في
ايضا اخبار الامريكان النديه التي يتعامل
بها السعوديه سواء في اوبك بلس او سواء في
التقارب مع ايران او في الانفتاح على
الصين او مع بشار الاسد كل هذه الامور
تدفع لامريكا ان تعيد حساباتها وان تعطي
متاخره الان بارسال هذه الغواصه التي لن
تغير الكثير امريكا عندها 30 الف عسكري
موجودين من الكويت الى عمان وفي العراق
وفي وفي سوريا يعني هذه فقط اطمئنه وليس
اكثر من ذلك ان سياسه النفط مقابل الامن
اذا مستمره التي بدات في طبعا 45 ايام رز
فلت الملك سعود على العموم ان نشكرك عبد
الله الشاجي ونشكر ايضا دكتور خليل
العناني
ونتابع معكم
لن نعود الى تسريب وثائق سريه امريكيه
الصحيفه
نقلت عن مسؤولين امريكيين قولهم انه من
المرجح ان يكون للتسريب تاثير على الامن
القومي للولايات المتحده عالميا ونقلت
الصحيفه عن المسؤولين الامريكيين قولهم
ايضا ان الكشف عن معلومات شديده الحساسيه
يثير قلق المسؤولين الامنيين والحلفاء
الان لمناقشه هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من
جنابه العقيد الكسندر
الرئيس تحرير المجله العسكريه السويسريه
اهلا وسهلا بك اذا
وثائق مسربه في وقت حرج جدا وحساس كل
الانظار الان والتخوفات من اندلاع حرب
نوويه وما الى ذلك انت بتقييمك لهذا
التسريب هل هو فعلا
مبرر مبرر لهذه المخاوف الكبيره
في حقيقات الامر لست متاكدا هل الامر اياد
تعلق بتسريب لكن من الاكيد ان الامر يتعلق
بوضع معلومات وهذا طبعا يحدث في وقت يتوقع
الجميع ان تقوم اوكرانيا باطلاق هجمات
مضاده اذا التوقيت الان
مهم جدا وهذا يعني بان روسيا مهتمه
لتقديم هذه الحمله من المعلومات اذا شئنا
نسميها
ما تقصده يعني انت تقول الامر ليس
بالضروره التسريب بمعنى ان هذه المعلومات
وضعت قصدا لكي يتم تداولها في هذه الفتره
لمصلحه من لفائده من
اعتقد ان هذا تم وضعه على الانترنت
بقصد واضح واذا ما كانت هذه المعلومات
الموجوده فهي طبعا ممزوجه للمعلومات اخرى
غير صحيحه هناك بعض المعلومات الغير
الصحيحه هناك اشاره طبعا
وهو روسي معروف بنشر المعلومات المضلله
على العموم سنتابع طبعا هذه
المعلومات وراءها ومن يقف وراءها ونشكرك
جزيلا سيد الكسندر شكرا
[موسيقى]
التزامني مع زياره وفد من المشرعين
الامريكيين لتايوان وبعد عوده رئيستها من
الولايات المتحده اعلنت الصين عن مناورات
عسكريه تحاكي تطويقا كاملا للجزيره يعود
التوتر الى مضيق تايوان مع ارتفاع وتيره
اللقاءات بين المسؤولين التايوانين
والمشرعين الامريكيين في وقت تتمسك فيه
الادارات الامريكيه المتعاقبه بما تعتبره
غموضا استراتيجيا في موقفها وما تعتبره
بيجين تشجيعا وتسليحا امريكيا لتايوان
تحذير لمن تصفهم بيجين بالانفصاليين يجري
الجيش الصيني تدريبات عسكريه لمده ثلاثه
ايام في مضيق تايوان تقول الصين ان
المناورات رد على تواطؤ مع قوى خارجيه
وتركز التدريبات على القدره على السيطره
على البحر والجو والاعلام في سيناريو
تطويق كامل للجزيره
وشهدت في محيط تايوان سفن عسكريه صينيه
وطائرات المقاتله تحلق بالقرب من اجوائها
واقتربت احدى السفن الصينيه من جزيره
بنجتان التي تقع على بعد 126 كيلومترا عن
تايوان من جهتها افادت وزاره الدفاع
التايوانيه بتعقب اثنتين واربعين طائره
عسكريه صينيه في محيط الجزيره وقالت انها
رصدت 29 مقاتله اخترقت خط المنتصف في
المضيق فيما وصفته بزعزعه الامن
والاستقرار وتعريض المنطقه للخطر موضحه
انها ارسلت طائرات وسفن حربيه واستخدمت
منظومات صواريخ ارضيه لمراقبه طائرات
الجيش الصيني تطورات تاتي اياما بعد عوده
رئيسه تايوان من زياره للولايات المتحده
التقت خلالها رئيس مجلس النواب كيفن
ماكارتي وهي خطوه اثارت غضبا صينيا كما
تتزامن المناورات الصينيه مع استقبال
رئيسه تايوان وفدا من المشرعين الامريكيين
يقوده مايكل ماكول رئيس لجنه الشؤون
الخارجيه بمجلس النواب خلال اللقاء
لتقديم الدعم للجزيره وهو ما ردت عليه
سانغو بان تتطلع الى مزيد من تعزيز
التعاون الامني مع الولايات المتحده
وطالما كانت تقارب بين واشنطن نذيرا
بزياده منسوب التوتر في مضيق تايوان ففي
عام 95 من القرن الماضي واحتجاجا على
زياره الرئيس التايواني
انذاكوي الى الولايات المتحده اعلنت الصين
تجارب اطلاق صواريخ في المياه المحيطه
بتايوان وفي السنه الماضيه زارت رئيسه
مجلس النواب الامريكي ناسي بيلوسي تايوان
ثم توالت بعد ذلك لقاءات المسؤولين
التايوانيين والمشرعين الامريكيين فردت
الصين بالاعلان عن اكبر مناورات جويه
وبحريه وفي الوقت الذي تحتفظ فيه واشنطن
بسياسه الغموض الاستراتيجيه تبدو بجين
اكثر صراحه في فعلها ورد فعلها في مساله
تايوان
ومعنى الان من لندن ان
محلل الاستراتيجيه العسكريه في الفريق
الدولي لدراسات الامن اهلا وسهلا بك سيد
كافالو في الحصاد اذا
المناورات الان
كيف تقراها هل هي الرساله الاقصى التي
ترسلها الصين للولايات المتحده بما يتعلق
في تايوان ام مجرد بالون اختبار في هذه
الفتره
الليله شكرا على الاستضافه لماذا تحدث هذه
المناورات في المرحله الرهينه اعتقد ان
الصين تقوم بمناورات ردا على ما حدث من
زيارات وهذا ليس بجديد في العام الماضي
ايضا كانت هناك زياره
للجزيره لكن هذه المناورات الان مختلفه
والصين تتتبع سياسه واضحه فيما يخص تايوان
والصين
تحاول ان تظهر القوه او تستعرض القوه من
خلال
المناورات العسكريه وهي تقوم باطلاق
الصواريخ وتسير دوريات في المضيق لكن لا
اعتقد ان الصين في المرحله الراهنه
ستتجاوز هذه الامور نعم
الجزيره في العام الماضي وبيجين انتظرت
الى حين انقضاء الزياره وبعد ذلك اعلنت
الصين عن اطلاق مناورات عسكريه وبدات
بتسير دوريات من خلال الطائرات حربيه في
الصين تحاول استعراض
العضله وتحاول ايضا فرض عقوبهم على ولكن
الان اعتقد ان تتجاوز هذا الحد ولا يمكن
ان ننسى زله اللسان هذا اذا امكن وصفها
بذلك التي اقدم عليها بايدا عندما تحدث عن
التزام الولايات المتحده بدعم تايوان
عسكريا والسؤال هل ستقف واشنطن وتتفرج على
هذه المناورات ام يمكن ان نتوقع رده فعل
في المستقبل القريب
هي من المراقبين لهذه المناورات العسكريه
الصينيه
وتحاولوا ان تستكشف كيف بامكان الصين ان
تنشر قواتها ليس فقط في مضيق تايوان لكن
ايضا في بحر الصين الجنوبي وباتجاه ايضا
اليابان الولايات المتحده الامريكيه تتابع
عن كتب كل صغيره وكبيره لكن الالتزام
الموجود لدى الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
اتجاه تايوان ليس ذاته الموجود
لواشنطن اتجاه اليابان نحن نعرف ان
امريكيين مهتمين بتايوان لكن الامريكان
ايضا يقومون
بتدريب القوات التايوانيه وهناك تتبع
ومراقبه لكن الالتزام
اتجاه تايوان يختلف عن الالتزام اتجاه
الدول الاخرى هناك ايضا انقسام في هذا بين
الديمقراطيين
والجمهوريين الديمقراطي مثلا لديهم التزام
كامل اتجاه اليابان اذا ما هاجمت الصين
اليابان لكن الامر مختلف فيما يخص
تايوان نعم امريكا ستحاول مساعده تايوان
اذا ما حدث اي هجوم قد تقوم بنفس الشيء
الذي تقوم به مع اوكرانيا مثلا من خلال
ارسال اسلحه وما شابه ذلك
اشكركالو المح لل المحلل استراتيجيه
العسكريه في الفريق الدولي لدراسه الامن
كنت معنا من لندن شكرا
[موسيقى]
لقي اربعه من طالبي اللجوء الافارقه
مصرعهم
وفقد ثلاثه 23 في حديثي غرق الجمعه والسبت
قباله سواحل تونس بينما تم انقاذ ثلاثه
وخمسين اخرين وفق افاده لمحكمه صفاقس
واسفرت مثل هذه الحوادث قباله السواحل
التونسيه عن مصرعي او فقدان اكثر من مئه
شخص وذلك منذ مطلع مارس الماضي فقط
ماساه الطالب اللجوء الى اوروبا واحدث
فصول الماساه تاتي من تونس
السلطات التونسيه اعلنت السبت انتشال اربع
جثث لطالبي لجوء افارقه قباله الساحل
صفاقس جنوبي البلاد وانقاذ ثلاثه وخمسين
ولا يزال ثلاثه وعشرون في عداد المفقودين
وقالت ان ذلك حدث خلال حادثي غرق منفصلين
يومين الجمعه والسبت بالقرب من تلك
المنطقه
تونس اصبحت بعد ليبيا نقطه انطلاقا رئيسيه
لطالب اللجوء من الافارقه وغيرهم وتحذر
قوات خفر السواحل من استمرار تدفقهم
واستخدامهم وسائل التقليديه غير امنه في
رحلاتهم وتقول السلطات التونسيه انها
انقذت 27 الفا وستمائه وخمسه وستين من
طالب اللجوء كانوا في الطريق لايطاليا
الربع الاول من العام الحالي وان وحدات
الحرس الوطني في الداخل والساحل احبطت منذ
بدايه العام وحتى نهايه مارس الماضي نحو
500 عمليه كما جرى ضبط ثلاثه وستين من
الضلعين في تنظيم عمليات التهريب او
التوسط لاتمامها وجرى حجز 135 وسيله بحريه
واثنتي عشره سياره تستعمل في هذه العمليات
تكرار الحوادث بهذه الوتيره السريعه يدق
ناقوس الخطر في تونس والدول الاوروبيه على
السواء خاصه وان بعض السواحل التونسيه
تبعد 150 كيلومترا فقط من جزيره لامبا
دوزا الايطاليه وتقول الخريه التونسيه
انها في امس الحاجه للتمويل والمعدات
الفعاله لحمايه حدودها بشكل افضل وان
المعدات التي تلقتها في السابق من ايطاليا
قديمه وغير
وتدخل موجات الهجره الوافده عبر تونس ضمن
الحمله الواسعه التي تقودها رئيسه الوزراء
الايطاليه جورجيا ميلوني وحكومتها في هذا
الصدد وتسعى ميلوني لاقداع الاتحاد
الاوروبي بتكثيف جهود دعم الاستقرار في
تونس في تجنب موجات الهجره التي وصفتها
بانها غير مسبوقه وتشكل خطرا ليس لايطاليا
وحدها وانما للعديد من الدول الاوروبيه
[موسيقى]
اول من عرض مخطط التقسيم المكاني والزماني
للمسجد الاقصى المبارك كان هو اليمين
الاسرائيلي متطرف بقياده حزب النيكود وذلك
تمهيدا لتهويد المسجد من خلال سياسه
الاقتحامات والاعتداءات المتكرره على
المرابطين داخله وفق تقرير مؤسسه القدس
الدوليه يخطط الاحتلال الاسرائيلي لفرض
التقسيم المكاني للاقصى عبر الاستيلاء على
منطقتين الاولى في الجهه الغربيه امام باب
المغاربه
وقربه حائط البراق الذي يقيم عنده اليهود
طقوسهم التلموديه بذريعه انه حائط المبكى
كما يسمونه المنطقه الثانيه المنطقه
الثانيه تقع في الجهه الشرقيه لجهه مقبره
باب الرحمه والتي صدر الاحتلال جزءا منها
وهي المنطقه التي يؤدي اليهود عندها بعض
الطقوس وذلك مقابل قبه الصخره
كيف تتحدث مصادر عن تخصيص اجزاء ومساحات
من المسجد الاقصى يقتنها اليهود ليحولوها
لكونس يهوديه لاداء صلواتهم فيها يشمل
التقسيم المكاني كذلك بسط السيطره بالقوه
على جميع الساحات الخارجيه التي تحيط
بالمسجد الاقصى الاماكن المسقوفه مثل
المسلق قبه الصخره والمصلى المرواني فتكون
للمسلمين
ليس سرا ان الجماعات الدينيه اليهوديه
تسعى لاقامه الهيكل المزعوم على انقاذ
المسجد الاقصى اما مخطط التقسيم الزماني
فهذا بحث يهدف الى تخصيص اوقات محدده
لدخول المسلمين للمسجد الاقصى وكذلك اوقات
اخرى خاصه باليهود بحيث يتم اقتسام
الساعات والايام طوال العام بين المسلمين
واليهود
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي يرى ان على المسلمين
افراغ المسجد الاقصى يوميا وذلك من الساعه
السابعه والنصف حتى الحاديه عشره صباحا
في فتره الظهيره في يمتد الوقت من الواحده
والنصف وحتى الثانيه والنصف وفي فتره
ثالثه بعد العصر لتكون هذه الاوقات مخصصه
لليهود فقط
كذلك يسعى هذا المخطط لتخصيص المسجد
الاقصى لليهود خلال اعيادهم التي تصل الى
100 يوم بالاضافه الى جميع ايام السبت
يصل عدد الايام المخصصه وفق هذا المخطط
لليهود قرابه مئه وخمسين يوما في العام
ولاحكام السيطره على المسجد عاده يمنع
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي من تقل اعمارهم عن
اربعين عاما من دخول المسجد وتحضر
المخابرات الاسرائيليه ما تسميه تنظيم
المرابطين والمرابطات الذين يقومون على
خدمه المسجد
تبلغ او
تبلغ اسرائيل بالاحرى عددا كبيرا من ابناء
القدس والداخل الاسرائيلي المحتل ممن
يواظبون على الصلاه في المسجد الاقصى بشكل
منتظم تبلغهم بضروره ان يبتعدوا عن المسجد
مده ما تزيد على سته اشهر تجدد بعد انتهاء
كل فتره
اذا هذا بالمختصر الفكره وراء التقسيم
المكاني والزماني حتى الان او المخطط
اليهودي القائم من القدس لمناقشه هذا
الموضوع معنا ناصر الهدمي رئيس الهيئه
المقدسيه
لمناهضه التهويد اهلا وسهلا بك استاذ ناصر
اذا هذا المخطط حياك الله هذا المخطط يعني
هو بداه اليمين المتطرف والان يعني ليس
هناك حكومه اكثر تطرفا مما تشهده
اسرائيل اليوم هل الى حد كبير هذا المخطط
مرتبط بالحكومه ام انه مستمر بغض النظر عن
من يتسلم رئاسه الحكومه
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم تحيه لك ولجمهور
المشاهدين لا لا شك ان هذا برنامج
استراتيجي مستمر بغض النظر عن الحكومات
بمعنى انه حينما كانت حكومه الاحتلال
يراسها الذي اتهم انه يساري وانه معروف
عنه انه لا يحترم حرمه السبت ولا يقوم
بالشعائر الدينيه ولكن مع ذلك حينها وما
تحذيرات كل
الذين حوله
بضروره وقف الاقتحامات المسجد الاقصى
المبارك في رمضان الفائت الا انه اصر على
ان تبقى هذه الاقتحامات بمعنى ان موضوع
تهويد المسجد الاقصى المبارك موضوع
استراتيجي محوري لدى حكومه الاحتلال جزء
منه يعبر عن سياده الاحتلال وعن رؤيه دوله
الاحتلال لارض المسجد الاقصى المبارك على
انها جزء من ارض اسرائيل يجب ان تكون
السيطره حامل لها وهذا ايضا يفسر ما قامت
به السلطات الاحتلال من
تقليص وهجوم على السياده الاردنيه كذلك في
المسجد الاقصى المبارك وسياده دائره
الاوقاف الاسلاميه كل هذا وفق الاطار
العريض الذي يعبر عنه ان الاحتلال يرى
سيادته منقوصه اذا لم تكن مفروضه على
المسجد الاقصى المبارك بالذات ايقونه
السياده الان نعم مشروع التهويد مشروع
مستمر لن يتوقف بتغير الحكومات وكما ذكرت
حضرتك نعم الحكومه الحاليه هي الاشد تطرفا
الاشد
فاشيه وهي التي يعني تدعو الى تغيير الوضع
القائم في ضمن سلسله حلقات باتجاه نعم
بناء المسجد الاقصى بناء هيكل اسطوري مكان
المسجد الاقصى المبارك الى اي حد سيسمح
بهذا المخطط لان يتم انجازه بشكل كامل هل
المجتمع الدولي له كلمه في هذا الخصوص هل
يمكن ان يمارس اي نوع من الضغط
لمنعه ايقافه عقلته
المجتمع الدولي لم يكن في يوم من الايام
قادر او معني بوقف الاحتلال بوقف جرائم
الاحتلال في ارض فلسطين ومنها اعتداءات
الاحتلال على المسجد الاقصى المبارك ولكن
يعني من التجربه شهدنا ان وقفه الشعب
الفلسطيني هي الوحيده القادره على لجم
الاحتلال وربما تاخير تنفيذ مخططاته وربما
الغائها يعني نعود الى الوراء في عام 2017
حينما اراد الاحتلال ان يضع بوابات
الكترونيه على مدخل المسجد الاقصى المبارك
وهذا كان ايضا خطوه مهمه بالنسبه للاحتلال
للسيطره على من يدخل الى المسجد الاقصى
المبارك واعداد الداخلين على الرغم من انه
الان ربما تكون يعني نعيش في ظروف قريبه
من هذا الامر الا انه في حينه استطاع
المقدسيون ان يجبروا سلطات الاحتلال على
التراجع على خلع حتى البوابات الالكترونيه
التي وضعت بشكل اولي على مدخل المسجد
اليوم هذه الايام المباركه المسجد الاقصى
هو في دائره الضوء خصوصا لانها تستغل عاده
في مثل هذه الى اي حد ما يجري الان
يعني يضع الامور يحدد المرحله المقبله
الى حد كبير خليني اقول كالتالي حكومه
الاحتلال الان تمر وفق ضغوطات كثيره جزء
منها داخليه موضوعيه وجزء منها
لها دخل بالشعب الفلسطيني هو جزء منها
ايضا لها دخل في الشعوب العربيه
والاسلاميه والمحيط الذي تعيش في دوله
الاحتلال لذلك نعم ما يجري في هذه الايام
خطير جدا له تبعاته الاحتلال اليوم بالذات
هذه الليله يعني هذه الليله خطيره جدا
بالنسبه للاحتلال اذا استطاع ان يمرر
ارادته على موضوع الاعتكاف في المسجد
الاقصى المبارك او لم يستطع لم يستطع هي
كارثه كبرى بالنسبه للاحتلال واذا استطعت
يواجه ايضا كارثه اكبر وهي ربما ان ان
يقضي
الاحتلال لياليه وليالي العيد في الملاجئ
وكل هذه المحاذير يعيش الاحتلال اشكرك
استاذ ناصر الهدمي من القدس شكرا جزيلا
[موسيقى]
ثمه امور واحداث صادمه في مناطق متفرقه من
العالم نتوقف امامها في ذهول يتصدره سؤال
عريض لماذا على سبيل المثال قتل مسلحون
سبعه وثلاثين شخصا على الاقل في هجوم على
مدرسه تضم نازحين فروا من اعمال العنف في
شمال وسط نيجيريا في مجزره هي الثانيه في
المنطقه هذا الاسبوع في بوركينا فاسو ايضا
السلطات تقول اليوم ان هجومين وقعا في
شمال البلاد واسفر عن مقتل 44 مدنيا مساء
يوم الخميس بعد ان يصدمك عدد من من فقدوا
ارواحهم دفعه واحده تبحث عن الدوافع تاره
يقول العارفون بالنزاع في هذه المنطقه او
تلك السبب هو العنف الطائفي تاره يقولون
انه صراع بين مزارعين رحل ومزارعين مقيمين
على الوصول للاراضي والموارد
تتعدد الاسباب والتحليلات والوقائع ولكن
تبقى الحقيقه المؤسفه وهي حجم العنف الذي
يسود عالمنا دون رغبه او قدره على ايقاف
هم دمتم بخير وبسلام في
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]